[Music]
some of the most interesting studies
into near-death and out-of-body
experiences were run by the Air Force
right as airplanes got faster and faster
and faster over the past 20 years right
pilots kept flying themselves into G LOC
gravity induced loss of consciousness
right and they kept crashing so a guy
named James whinnery was was a guy kind
of charged with solving this problem and
what he did is down in Texas he spun
like thousand pilots in a giant
centrifuge into G lock right and as he
was doing it he noticed something
interesting the G lock means you pass
out and if you've experienced it what
actually happens is your vision forms
into a tunnel it looks like if you're if
you're watching it looks like an old
television set turning off where it goes
down into one point and then disappears
right so it looks experientially a lot
like you're walking down a long dark
tunnel which is kind of one of the
classic near-death experience phenomenon
what he discovered along the way is that
as he started spitting people towards G
lock kind of the longer he spun them
people started reporting out-of-body
experiences and after they were out of
the body if he kept spinning them it
would turn into a near-death experience
right so he's the person who has air
force is the person you know the US Air
Force discovered that out-of-body
experiences and near-death experiences
are actually on the same continuum
they're they're part of the same chain
of effect and a lot of it has to do with
the right temporal lobe there's other
things going on as well and there are of
course certain mysteries right there are
unsolved things and near-death
experiences we've got lots and lots and
lots of research that shows people
report things when they were supposedly
dead that they should not have known
about at all so there are people who
died on operating tables right in
research studies came back were brought
back they had near-death experiences and
while they were dead the nurse would
take their glasses off and put it in a
drawer and later when everybody was
running around looking around for their
glasses
the person who was on the operating
table the time the patient who was dead
at the time said oh yeah they're in the
bottom drawer over there and this is a
Pimm's my mom will study that was
actually done in the Netherlands this is
where that actually happened but there's
a lots and lots of experiences like that
so somewhere along the line information
is getting through right we don't know
that yet that's still the mystery but a
lot of the other stuff we understand the
biology behind it now
[Music]